it's times like these
we learn to love memes again we got to
give back to the community of people who
just want to laugh
so here we are visiting reddit
slash r slash programmer humor
yeah okay let's let's have a look let's
have a laugh let's get into some
some programming memes programming okay
here we go what do we got top of the
meme list it reminds me of chris nolan's
short film
dad there is a recursion under my bed
what do we got
well i don't know i don't know what else
i thought it would be but
dad there's a recursion under my bed
we're gonna run out of memory stack
overflow
all right startups be like
which language should we use for the new
this new project
the trendiest the coolest the one most
of us know
yeah throw that guy out trendiest and
coolest only
languages it doesn't it doesn't need to
be
easy or proper it just needs to be
trendy that's how you get projects done
you just pick the trendiest language and
boom you're
pretty much automatically done without
even programming just because the trend
you just gotta make a little article say
hey we're making a new project we're
using this language and the project
finishes itself don't even have to learn
it
ah this guy coining recursion
until a terminating cast is met
all right let's have a read
if i had a nickel for every time i got
confused i'd be like where'd
this nickel come from and there'd be
another nickel and i'd think
what's with the nickels leading to more
nickels and confusion and eventually i'd
slowly be crushed by nickels without
ever knowing why
that's what programming is like
sometimes you're just
you know lost in those abstractions
and you're going deeper and deeper and
deeper and then you find out
way at the bottom that it just does
nothing
except crush you to crush your ability
to learn the code base
all right comrade python other languages
you can make your classes
private or public python or class
okay i i don't fully understand this
meme but
it still makes me laugh just because
this rabbit's face
it's amazing
when your worst developers decide when
your worst developers decide to pair
program apes together strong
why does everyone rag on pair
programming so much
if they say like half the product or
you get the productivity of one person
with two people
i feel like there's some benefit to it
but
i get it i get it everyone wants to
prove they're independent
i can prove i'm useful i can prove it
i'm i'm independent
thus i'm useful i don't know if it's
really like that
let us not forget those who showed us
the way
see oh
this is this is a wholesome meme right
here this is one
i can get behind
i don't know if i agree with uh
the orange turtle who's the only turtle
i should do this so raphael
b and c plus plus i feel like it should
be donatello i don't know donatello
being c sharp is pretty accurate too
i'm i'm pretty is this michelangelo i
forget i haven't watched turtles in
years
it's been too long i purge my memory
every year okay let's see what we got
here i do we like that
what tech people think scientists need
help with and what scientists actually
need okay what tech people think
scientists need help with
all right all right i feel like this
one's gonna hit home but we'll see
please our data is too complex can you
magic machine can your magical machine
minds
unearth the patterns that lie within we
shall marshal our
finest algorithms
a few weeks in june the lab was infested
by wasps so we had to take pictures of
the equipment through the window
how do you get graphs from polaroid
photo into
excel
um polaroid photos
to excel photos in excel
uh okay i i don't quite see why this is
i i kind of get it but i don't think
it's hidden
it's not hitting close enough to home
i'll give it a i'll give it a half a
star
half a star the cat looks at the rain
and sits on the code
that draws it all
this is just this is just something i
would like i wouldn't have an animated
background of this
i'm not sure why this is humor other
than you know cats do this
but
okay that that was cool i'm gonna go
with that's cool
not sure why it's funny also
cats are overrated oh man here come the
down votes
here come the down votes no i like cats
i just don't i just don't like owning a
cat because
then you have to scoop a litter box
every day and feed it
and get scratched and there's fur
everywhere and fur
fur gets in your on i pressed a button
then fur gets in your mouse thing and
makes it go crazy
we lost our space we lost our spot i
guess that's the end of the video i
guess
no we gotta go we got four we got four
more minutes we gotta go a little
further okay
debugging be like eight hours later
yes this is exactly like it
why is debugging so hard why are
programs so buggy
why is everyone writing so many bugs
ah there's a lot of reasons for it
oh man yeah i i was once
stuck on a everybody has a stuck on a
bug story leave your stuck on a bug
story
down below and and remove that down vote
from me saying it
didn't want a cat and change it into an
up though turn
turn the button you want you want me to
turn blue blue
sound muted that's that's fine no we
don't need sound
all you need is my voice that's that's
definitely all you need
oh geez oh geez yeah
what get what bugs bugs me with bugs is
when
it's only a buggy on one compiler and on
other ones it's fine that that's what
gets me
that drives me crazy because it's like
you just can't can you just
uh work on the other one if you work on
this one
all right choose your router know the
work rules
appropriate cisco nice data susan
oh you're sweet nice data
susan oh it's huawei inappropriate hello
government
hello government who always spying on me
all right ah
not that funny whatever time travel
andrew trask if you were
dropped 2 000 years back in time with
nothing but the knowledge you have now
what would you do
warn them about javascript here we go
here we go everybody hating javascript
i've been guilty i've been guilty but i
don't hate it anymore
i i think javascript's probably okay
it's it's just it's like a trend to not
like it it's like nickelback
javascript is the nickelback of
programming languages
i'll let someone else figure that out
okay 0.1 plus point two equals point
three
zero zero zero four
javascript uh i think every language
does that
pretty sure that happens everywhere
that's a weird that's a weird thing to
still have a problem with in this day
and age though but
i remember reading about it and hearing
about it multiple times about why but i
always forget it's basically something
to do with
something to do with the bites and the
bits
but yeah it's a thing that's why you
always gotta have a margin of error when
you're adding floats
cast it into test why shouldn't it go to
prod
cast it into test test it no
merged
ah beautiful me rereading the code
i wrote a month ago oh god yeah
yeah this is me every time i'm always
like what was i thinking
what is this syntax who wrote this oh
i did committed one month ago
oh man oh man they're hidden
close to home today they're just hidden
real close i need this shirt
programmer and pro grammar
an organism that turns caffeine and
pizza
into software yeah that's that's how the
meme goes
everybody thinks we just drink caffeine
and eat pizza
and i'm here to tell you that that's
true
except pizza can be substituted with any
easy food
the thing is you see programmers don't
want to waste time cooking
we're too busy so we just order a pizza
throw pizza in the oven forget about it
let it burn a little bit
because we forgot about it and didn't
set a timer unless you're a pro
pro programmer and you program your
timer
into what you're writing and i don't
know i was trying to go somewhere with
that but i'm just gonna abandon
abandon that joke uh
yeah yeah it's just this is too trendy
too trendy to be funny anymore
open source is communism for softwares
change my mind
i'm not going to get political here i
refuse to get political here on code
technologies
thumbs up for non-political content
i only care about our well-being and our
knowledge
i don't care about what you think
of
yeah political stuff you coming or not
get in loser we're going straight to
productions
oh i don't know why i laughed so much at
that i think it's i think it's the look
on this
girl's face i don't know what movie this
is i feel like this is clueless or
something i don't know
development in a nutshell front end
let's just let's just cut it off
right there front end that's a nice
picture and then back end
yeah yeah it did too be like that
it's that's pretty accurate or at least
you try
i think for most programmers though the
back end and the front end will look
like this whole octopus thing because uh
you know unless you're a front-end
developer you just you don't really care
about the interface
you just need it to work and make a
little bit of sense
but you don't need it to be like pretty
because
he's gonna care if it's pretty who's
going to care
other than everybody who looks at it
project managers after seeing a
competent developer
i can milk you oh god oh god
this is so true
ah joshua fluke will tell you that this
is true
he will tell you go ask him ask him if
this means true or not
and he'll say yeah yeah this is how it
works
he'll make a video about it day in the
life of a project manager
seeing a competent developer
bust out the mudders let's get some milk
out of this guy
he can write the whole code base in one
day with no errors
push it straight to production we'll
just milk all that we'll just absorb all
the money give them
give them 10 bucks an hour that'll do
make like i'll make like 120
we'll make like 120 million it's a good
deal
milk it all right last one last one
today i experienced this when you use
shift to capitalize the first letter but
the caps locks is already on
i should not laugh so hard at this but
it looks so funny
this is how people do the uh the insane
memes
when you he should have done that with
all this text that would have been
funnier
yeah i do this all the time i do it all
the time because
there's like so many things that require
all caps and you just hit caps lock and
then type the word like when you're
using cmake or something
you just hit caps type the word and then
when you go on and try to do a normal
a normal sentence or something yeah this
happens
is that adam sandler i think it's adam
sandler
all right guys that's it that's it for
this episode
of programming humor programming memes
whatever i ended up calling it in the
title i don't know we'll see
so don't forget to uh do all the stuff
help support this channel help support
the memes if you had a laugh
let me know let me do
i don't know you know all the normal
stuff people say appreciate
everyone appreciate the the views i
appreciate the comments
i do i read them i try to respond unless
i don't know what to say
and then i might respond and just be
like huh or not you know alright see you
in the next episode
peace out